I want to talk to you about pH c c ph c
c what does it stand for what does it
mean and how does it affect you P stands
for patients way too many people in this
space are not patient everybody like why
isn't it happening I've been doing this
for six months are you kidding me you're
building a business the next point is H
hustle you've heard me talk about
hostile 2.0 it goes back you've got to
work your face off that's the bottom
line folks you've got to work really
hard and you've got to continue to
commit to your product hustle for your
monetization nothing's gonna come to you
don't act and let somebody else do it
for you you need to hustle for yourself
especially in the beginning phases and
finally C and C and that is content if
there wasn't substance nobody would care
you have a little substance people
didn't respect it so you got to make
sure you have that content down you need
to know your stuff don't go to a space
you don't understand because the trend
is going there that's some bull crap do
what you know and community that is the
core of having anything valuable you got
to give you've got to give and you've
got to give some more of my friends
answer every email answer every lead
shake every hand go to every conference
of these people cuz that's what it's
about
you put these four pieces together and
some stuff is gonna go down it's gonna
be awesome as long as you recognize what
your passion is and what your content
can be best about by understanding what
you do best pH CC patience hustle
content and community